so I think that chat gbt is fascinating
will it replace certain jobs yeah yeah
it will like for example I had it write
a press release wasn't perfect but it
was pretty good I think what chat gbt is
going to do it's gonna do shitty first
drafts you know that's what it's gonna
do and instead of spending a week to
write a shitty first draft that has to
be edited the computer will write a
shitty first draft in a few seconds and
then you still need somebody to edit it
so um I think with the need for really
good editors of every sort press
releases you know poetry whatever it is
is gonna Skyrocket so I think that's
gonna happen also remember chat gbt
pulls from the internet in other words
it it cannot do original thoughts it can
only regurgitate what's already been
written so where human beings will
continue to dominate is if you have
original thought
you're completely safe